this morning a trip on the atlantic to
explore an ancient sport and a
modern-day message
josh jorgensen is the founder of black
tip h he's become the world's most
popular fishing star on social media
jorgensen is obsessed with trying to
reel in sea monsters and more viewers
all while trying to make sure his kids
get a chance to do the same
no guys this goliath weighs he's bigger
than the boat he's bigger than the phone
dude his videos on youtube passed a
billion views last year oh wow these
ones are much stronger we're here again
with sam barrington and captain ben
chancey they feature big names who's
having fun
and even bigger fish the biggest fish
you've ever seen yes it's been quite a
journey for a kid who grew up north of
the border in windsor ontario how does a
kid from canada
become the world's number one social
media fishing star
so i've always been absolutely in love
with fishing in
2003 my parents got a condo in florida
we started coming down here on vacation
i saw a guy catch a shark from the beach
i was like i have to start doing that
three minutes and 27 seconds
and the shark is winning so i started
catching sharks on the beach and then
i'd bring the pitchers home and no one
in canada believed that i caught them
from the beach they said oh you caught
it on a boat and brought it to shore
there's no sharks at the beach so i
started filming videos
and i posted on youtube i didn't know
what i was doing
[Music]
the videos took off and in 2008 josh
jorgensen created black tip h
fueled by advertising dollars from
youtube he set off on fishing adventures
around the world from just off his
current home base in jupiter florida
get away from get away from get away
from stuff could you do what you do
based anywhere besides here
i think starting off there's no way we
would have ever been able to capture the
items we did i don't live in florida
florida's amazing
that's where we pushed off for a day at
sea
for a look at the life of a mega
influencer on the atlantic oh my god
ron's gonna snap
this might be the winner i just wanted
to catch the biggest fish that's
physically possible to catch this boat's
he's almost half of it look at that
it was just this endless chase
to catch basically sea monsters this
thing's over 50 pounds that's something
that's been part of folklore mythology
it's been part of things for thousands
of years the big fish story i mean you
know you go back even to ancient
cultures there was this reverence of the
ocean there you go there we go oh damn
you s
it's not funny we started with fish that
for many anglers would be a prize
for jorgensen these spanish mackerel are
bait about a way to work up the food
chain so they're good eating and they're
also a great bait we're gonna use them
for bait to try to get them in
up next it was a black tip shark trying
to take the hook out just messes them up
too much and they hit their head too
much so we just cut the hook with the
bolt cutters and the other piece of the
hook just falls right out
there we go
he's free he's great he's gone he's good
he's
good
put this between your legs flip on what
am i doing you're just gonna hold on for
dear life followed by something even
larger
[Laughter]
what
a 300 pound goliath grouper
a fish that once almost ended
jorgensen's life
i did not realize that you'd been pulled
out of the boat and dragged yeah before
you put me yeah in a similar position
you're right
man i still got him you still got him he
still got the fish hit the rod
that was scary yeah that was really
interesting you know i was i was trying
to do it all by myself and that wasn't
smart which is why you had a couple
people spotting me yes but i just want
to be clear if that fish had
pulled me out of the boat come on it
would have gone straight yeah you would
have
for jorgensen the filming is just as
enjoyable as the fishing it's a nice
fish bro wow
but these days even more challenging
language is inappropriate today part of
the problem
a numbed audience
four grown men cannot pick this fish up
what worked two three years ago doesn't
work now what does it mean right now to
that what works
it'd always be like the fish would be
like they were a major part of the story
but we realized we've kind of caught
everything and so from a business
perspective we need to make it more
about the adventure and not so much
about
catching this one fish
[Music]
adventure and adrenaline may still pay
the bills
but they are not blacktip h's only
missions let's let them go jorgensen
says protection and preservation are
also a critical part of the operation
just reviving him right now we're going
to get him nice and
healthy and we're going to make sure he
gets to let go it's a lot of things but
we just really need to focus on our
water quality
and we need to focus on sustainable
fishing regulations you know we need to
reduce limits create more slot sizes we
need to let people catch less fish not
so much catching less keeping less do
you really need to keep 60 mahi a day no
it's ridiculous you know it takes hours
to fillet them and what do you do with
500 pounds of mahi meat
you can get a big one
all right i want my kids to enjoy what
i've enjoyed you know i want to have a
sustainable fishery it's really
important to respect the fish that
you're catching especially when you're
catching a large fish large fish are
normally breeders so you want to take
good care of them you want to make sure
that they are healthy when you release
them you want to make sure that you
don't fight them too long how much
different do you think the ocean looks
than when you first started this 15
years ago oh
so different there was so much more fish
back then and that's that's nothing
imagine what it was like 60 years ago
100 years ago
you know if i could have a time machine
i would go back to go fishing screw
everything else i would
yeah instead of delorean i'd build a
boat with the time machine you know hit
35 miles an hour and we could pick our
destination
i love it you've obviously been some
interesting places that was pretty
exciting i could tell
it was up there you were a little scared
of course you did a good job
i love this jeff this is so awesome yeah
that that's the one yeah that's the one
that got you yeah yeah
i mean you haven't lived until you've
caught a 300 pound goliath grouper
and and nearly get pulled out of the
boat by it yeah i would have enjoyed
seeing you
capsaicin
you would have more than enjoyed it yeah
i think i would have oh boy
well a golden brown crust filled with
hot and savory delights that's next
[Music]
if i had been pulled out
you just would have put it on loop yeah
but you know what you could have let go
of the line well no you can't the that's
the point that's why it's right yes
because the the rod is strapped
to you
so you're you're attached to it right
now oh no so if that thing would have
you know if i would have gone out of the
boat i mean they were holding on to me a
little bit but if i get out of the boat
there it dives to the bottom of the
ocean i'm 90 feet down
oh no i don't want that to happen
jeffrey so jeff how can you like give me
uh what is how what was that like like
the pulling the force of that can you
compare it it's incredible
no it's incredibly powerful and you feel
helpless for us for a minute because
you
you you can't win that battle right
right right um and i mean that's and you
can see the guy holding on to the back
there a little bit but it's there's
still a danger involved and that's a
it's a massive
fish that's
fighting you how does he find these
creatures i mean i've gone fishing
i've never pulled he has bigger things
like that
they have their spots in florida like
they they've they know some of these and
some of these places are off like
shipwrecks wherever else where the fish
gather their secret right there yeah i
mean everybody's got their own secret
fishing spots it's harder when you go
out into areas you've never been to like
when he travels internationally then it
gets a little trickier but remember he's
been catching sharks you know since he
was a teenager so it's something that
he's been doing for you know a long time
and i i love that he's taking care yes
of the ocean also it's a beautiful thing
well thank you so much for that pleasure
we loved it